so congratulations first of all on the
phone thank you thank you you guys
excited yeah i would say we're pretty
excited minimally
excited just a little bit you said you
shot this last summer and now it's
finally out yeah i know it seems like
forever ago i think it seems like
yesterday yeah yeah it seems like
yesterday
but you guys actually shot this at
google oh yeah we had a week at google
up in mountain view um in the bay area
uh near san francisco and it was awesome
because we had mostly just been in sets
that tried to recreate it and to be
actually there
was different because now there were
actually like smart people around us i
mean
people weren't smart but we shot most of
the movie in atlanta and our amazing
production designer and
set folks just like created this google
world in atlanta at georgia tech campus
and it you know once we finally showed
up at real google we couldn't believe
how accurate fake google was so much of
what you'll see is fake google but it is
pretty much exactly like real google so
i think they did a pretty good job oh my
god amazing like down to like the
smallest details like the name tags on
people's cubicles are exactly the same
they would do a lot of research um and a
lot of what they found on the campus at
google they brought their way into the
set i don't think i would know how to
even find google i mean can you google
google to find the address to go to
google i mean that's an excellent
question i feel like you can google
anything so yes probably but it's on
like major security lockdown so you
could get to google and then you would
be sort of like no yeah yes there's no
word to go beyond that well speaking of
google last night i was googling where i
could find this game and what do you
know toys r us had it so are you guys
familiar with this i don't think i've
seen one of those for well i won't age
myself but for a long time i won't
either but it was a while ago i have
played before and i'm not very good so i
figure let's just try this out and who
wants to go first
i'll go first do you want to sure
there's three modes i think one of them
laughs at you one of them sneezes and
the other one i'm not sure so i'll go
with i'm not sure okay this is why i
never went to med school okay well
that's one and then what do i do i just
said it then
so while she is working what was your
most favorite part about working on this
as opposed to something else
oh it was not working with tia circle
it's okay you can try again my favorite
part i think we had this very very fun
day where uh the
light towers outside of where we were
shooting had to be shut down because it
was raining too hard in atlanta and uh
our director was like what should we do
we just have this little delay so we put
on uh carly rae jepsen's call me maybe
yeah call me maybe and then we uh danced
around for a while it's on the internet
it is that was a really fun day is it on
youtube yeah it is on youtube perfect so
i was like this is this is not a bad way
to live let's switch the mode maybe try
the second one let's do this
okay there we go
i'm not sure what's happening right now
oh me maybe
what a great game
what'd you do okay i did it that's all
you just wanted you guys
definitely
i have a favorite app which is um yelp
or any any app that like um no she does
i'm sort of like a yelp wizard at this
point like especially when we were on we
were in atlanta we were in in san
francisco and then we were at uh google
in north in um mountain view so anytime
we'd be like okay we're gonna go to
dinner and be like i'm on it what kind
of cuisine do you want what kind of
price range are we talking about and i
would like find options i'd email
everybody i think it was a little bit
obnoxious but uh i one of my favorite
apps on my iphone is something that i've
had for years it is a game called poppy
jump
and it is a small red ball with a face
on it that bounces and you just have to
tilt your iphone right and left to make
it go up higher on platforms poppy jump
yeah i know how could you possibly see
it it's free so congratulations on the
film again is there anything else that
any secrets that you might want to tell
us before we if i let you guys go
that we can share
and if they can't share it wilson is uh
crazy good at sports really i know
people know that like the man can just
sort of walk in and be like hey what
what what are you guys playing and you
sort of just give him the basic premise
of what it is he's one of those and then
he's like oh can i see that and whatever
it is he just like excels at that
particular sport those people upset me i
know because i have to stand on the
sidelines and just you know watch an
envy that's awesome well thank you guys
so much
um yeah if you want to play operation
later just let me know okay
you